[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه الحلقه
الجديده من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
كيف توازن شل بين التوسع في النفط والغاز
واهداف الحياد المناخيه مقابله خاصه مع
رئيسه قطاع الاب ستريم في الشركه
[موسيقى]
واكبر واصلاح الهيكلي في منظومه الكهرباء
السعوديه نستطلعها مع الرئيسين التنفيذيين
لاهم شركتين في القطار
[موسيقى]
لنبدا حلقتنا من حيث انتهي عام 20 22
والذي شهد مطبات وتحولات كبيره في مسار
عمليه تحول الطاقه وبعد ان كانت اهداف في
الحياه الصفري تتصدر الاهتمام في عام 20
21 تصدرت صناعه الغاز المسال المشهد العمل
الماضي تغيرات كبيره شهدتها هذه الصناعه
على خلفيه ازمه الطاقه العالميه وتمنع
اوروبا عن استيراد الغاز الروسيه عبر
الانابيب لتشهد المراكز الاولى في قائمتي
اكبر المصدرين واكبر المستوردين للعام
الماضي تبدلات عده فقد صعدت الولايات
المتحده لتتراسس اكبر المصدرين متشاركه في
المرتبه الاولى مع قطر التي لا طالما
تربعت على عرش المصدرين لتصل صادرات كل من
البلدين العام الماضي الى 81 مليون
و200000 بحسب بيانات وكاله
وبالرغم من ان زياده صادرات عام 20 22
بالنسبه لقطر لم تكن كبيره الا انها كانت
كذلك واكثر بالنسبه للولايات المتحده التي
بدات لاول مره تصدير الغاز المسال عام
2016 كانتيجه مباشره
لثوره الغاز الصخري التي انطلقت عام 2005
ثوره تقنيه صاحبتها مليارات الدولارات من
الاستثمارات في محطات التسهيل حولت
الولايات المتحده من صافي مستورد الى صافي
مصدر للغازي المثال لتصبح امريكا بموجب
ذلك قوه عظمى في صناعه الغاز العالميه
ولولا ان حريقا شب في محطه فري بورد في
ولايه تكساس احد اكبر محطات التسهيل
الامريكيه والتي تشكل نحو 20% من اجمالي
قدرات التسيير الامريكيه فكانت الولايات
المتحده تربعت لوحدها على عرش كبار
المصدرين للع الماضي من دون منازع
وفي ضوئي ازمه الطاقه العالميه وقرار
اوروبا تنويع مصادر الغاز بعيدا عن روسيا
من المتوقع تشييد عدد جديد من محطات
التسهيل على ساحل الخليج الامريكي
وبالتالي استمرار نمو صادرات الغاز المسال
الامريكيه خلال السنوات القليله المقبله
الا ان المنافسه المحتدمه اليوم على مرتبه
اكبر مصدر للغاز المسال في العالم لن تطول
كثيرا فقطر تمضي قدما في مشاريع توسعه
عملاقه في حقل الشمال وفي قدراتها للتسهيل
ومن شبه المؤكد ان تعود لتتسيد كبار
المصدرين بدءا من عام 20 26 فصاعدا لتبقى
استراليا في المرتبه الثالثه خلال الفتره
المقبله التي ستشهد تنافسا امريكيا قطريا
على راس القائمه
وقد طال التغيرات عام 20 22 لائحه كبار
مستوردي الغاز المسال ايضا حيث عاده
اليابان لتحتل المرتبه الاولى بعد ان فقدت
هذا المركز عام 20 21 لصالح الصين لتستعيد
اليابان بذلك الصداره التي احتفظت بها
لسنوات طويله لكن ما زالت وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه تتوقع عوده الصين لانتزاع المركز
الاول كاكبر مستورد للغاز المسال في
العالم ابتداء من العام الحالي في ضوء
تخارج الصين من سياسات قيود الجائحه التي
اضعفت الطلب الصيني العمل الماضي الجدير
بالذكر ان الصين بدات استيراد الغاز
المسال لاول مره عام 2006 ثم اصبحت ثاني
اكبر مستورد للغاز المسال المتجاوزه كوريا
الجنوبيه عام 2017 لتصبح بعد ذلك عام 20
21 اكبر مستورد للغاز المثال متجاوزه
اليابان التي كانت قد تربعت على عرش
المستوردين لعقود مضت
[موسيقى]
شل واحده من اكبر خمس شركات دوليه في قطاع
النفط والغاز ولذلك تبقى تجربتها تحت
الانظار في تحقيق التوازن ما بين التوسع
في انشطتها التقليديه في النفط والغاز من
جهه والاستثمار في تحول الطاقه للوصول الى
صافي صفر انبعاثات من جهه اخرى في قلب هذا
التحدي تقف زوي يجنوفيتش الرئيس التنفيذيه
لاستكشاف والتطوير والانتاج في شركه شل
فهي المسؤوله عن استثمارات قطاع المنبع
والتي اثير حولها الكثير من الجدل
العالميا في السنوات الاخيره كانت لنا
فرصه لمقابله يجنوفيتش خلال زيارتها الى
ابو ظبي مؤخرا وسالتها بدايه عن مستهدفات
شال في الوصول الى صافي صفر انبعاثات
بحلول عام 20 50 وتحديدا الاهداف في
المرحليه على هذا الطريق
كيف حبيبي
تكون النيل
بعد شويه في كاميرا
كاسبر
ما هي توقعاتكم لوجهه اسواق الطاقه على
المدى القصير الى المتوسط في ظل كل هذه
العوامل المتغيره التي نشهدها مؤخرا
كده سامسونج
نتوقف الان مشاهدينا الكرام مع فاصلا قصير
نفتح بعده ملف الاصلاحات في منظومه
الكهرباء السعوديه فقومانه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه
تغييرات جذريه ادخلتها السعوديه على هيكل
قطاع الكهرباء لتحويلها الى منظومه
تنافسيه وتمهيد الطريقه امام مشاريع
الطاقات المتجدده والتي ستشكل 50% من مزيج
الطاقه بحلول عام 2030
واخر هذه التغييرات فصل الشركه السعوديه
لشراء الطاقه عن الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء
وتحويلها الى شركه مملوكه للدوله فما
الهدف من هذه التغيرات اللي نتابع هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
سوق تنافسيه للكهرباء هي المستهدف من
اعاده هيكله القطاع في السعوديه
ليتحول من هذا النموذج القديم الذي كان
يجمع كل الانشطه الرئيسيه تحت مظله شركه
واحده الى نموذج جديد يتم فيه الفصل بين
انشطه الشراء الطاقه والتوليد والنقل
والتوزيع قطاع التوليد او الانتاج تستحوذ
شركه السعوديه للكهرباء على حصه الثلثين
فيه تقريبا لكن هذه النسبه قد تتغير في
السنوات المقبله مع دخول المزيد من
منتج جديده اما التطور الاهم مؤخرا فكان
اتمام انتقال ملكيه الشركه السعوديه لشراء
الطاقه المسمات اختصارا المشتري الرئيس من
الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء الى الدوله في
اغسطس الماضي لتتولى شراء الطاقه من جميع
المنتجين واعاده بيعها لشركات التوزيع
لتصبح المسؤوله عن الطرح التنافسي
لمشروعات الطاقه المتجدده والتقليديه كما
تتولى شركه المشتري رئيس شراء الوقود من
ارامكو لتزويد منتجين الكهرباء ورفع كفاءه
استخدامه مع امكانيه البيع المباشر لكبار
المستهلكين مثل المصانع خطه اعاده
التنظيمي تهدف في النهايه الى رفع كفاءه
القطاع وتحرير السوق واتاحه المجال للعقود
الثنائيه بين المنتجين وكبار المستهلكين
بما يرثخ الشفافيه في العلاقات التجاريه
بين الاطراف العامله في قطاع الكهرباء هذا
الهيكل التنظمي التنافسي الكهرباء تتزايد
اهميته مع زياده حجم الطاقات المتجدده
التي يتم بنائها ففي العام الماضي تم
الاعلان عن توقيع اتفاقيات شراء الطاقه
لمشروعات الراس وسعد وليلى للطاقه الشمسيه
الكهروضوئيه لسعه 1091 ميجاوات والتي
ستسهم في جذب استثمارات تقدر بمليارين و
900 مليون ريال اما في العام الحالي فمن
المستهدف تطوير وطرح عشان مشروعات للطاقه
المتجدده بساعات سبعه جيجا وايت بما يشجع
القطاع الخاص للاستثمار وتعزيز الشركات مع
قطاع العام خصوصا مع تسجيل المملكه السعر
الاكثر تنافسيه على مستوى العالم في انتاج
طاقه الرياح والطاقه الشمسيه وبالتالي
لابد من مشتري مستقل ومنظما مستقل لشبكه
النقل وموزعين متعددين لضمان تساوي فرص
بين المنتجين ورفع كفاءه المنظومه
الكهربائيه ككل في
حول التغيرات التي طرات في منظومه الطاقه
السعوديه قابلت الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
السعوديه لشراء الطاقه مازن بهكلي وسالته
بدايه عن الدوري الذي تلعبه الشركه في
منظومه الطاقه بعد انفصالها عن الشركه
السعوديه للكهرباء
المشترى الرئيس همم
بعد انفصاله من الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء
اصبح كيان مستقل يعمل بحياديه وبكل شفافيه
في السوق لطرح مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده
والطاقه النظيفه بشكل عام والطاقه
التقليديه
لمنظومه الطاقه
وجود هذا الكيان يمثل همم فرصه واعده
للقطاع الخاص المشاركه في انتاج الطاقه
بشكل عام للطاقه التقليديه والطاقه
المتجدده ونعمل همم مع بقيه المنظومه بشكل
عام على تحقيق المزيج الامثل للطاقه
وكذلك رفع الطاقه المتجدده في همم في
المزيج بشكل عام وتحقيق مستدفات المملكه
في خفض الانبعاثات الكربونيه كذلك
طبعا انت اشرت لي مساله الطاقات المتجدده
المستهدف على اقل الان ااا كما هو يعني
معروف طاقات متجدده تفوق ال 60 جيجا وات
بحلول عام 2030 كيف يمكنكم التخطيط لدمج
هذه القدرات الكبيره والضخمه المتسارعه في
الشبكه ما هي التحديات كيف تواجهنا هو
عندنا الحقيقه خطه واضحه للطاقه المتجدده
والمزيد بشكل عام احنا سبق لنا مسبقا انه
المزيد
يقارب 50% من الطاقه المتجدده و50% من همم
طاقه الغاز بحلول 20 30 قد يكون هناك اكثر
من سيناريو همم بناء على نمو على على
الطلب واحنا مست- يعني مستعدين لذلك
منظومه بشكل عام همم
معالجه دخول الطاقه المتجدده والتحديات
التي لا علاقه بالطاقم جده من حيث
التقطعات في الانتاج يتم معالجتها
بالتخطيط المسبق
عن طريق دراسه المزيج الامثل في احجام
المشاريع بشكل عام التكنولوجيات
المستخدمه في هذا المشاريع كذلك الخطط
الاستخدام تخزين الطاقه كذلك بالاضافه الى
برامج اخرى لها علاقه في معالجه الاحمال
بشكل عام في في وقت الذروه فهي خطط
الحقيقه متكامله همم
تستقي من كميات البيانات الموجوده
وتستخدم الذكاء الصناعي كذلك في حساب
المزيد همم الامثل للطاقه بقياده وزاره
الطاقه والمشتري الرئيس يعمل على طرح هذه
المشاريع بالوقت المناسب والتوقيت المناسب
لتحقيق
السؤال الاخير يعني بالاشاره الى البيانات
والشبكات الذكيه والعدادات الذكيه هذا قم
بيانات ضخمه وهائله جدا كيف يساعدكم هذا
على التخطيط لليوم التالي
في القطاع الكهرباء في المملكه
البيانات المتوفره في الشبكه الحقيقه
تساعد بشكل كبير جدا ومشغل النظام على
التخطيط اليوم الثاني همم
واستخدام الافضل
وارخص
وكذلك همم اعلى كفاء القدرات الموجوده في
الشبكه بشكل عام واحنا نعمل همم بشكل
مصاحف جدا لمشغل النظام كمشتري الرئيس همم
بحيث ان احنا نتاكد من توفر القدرات
المطلوبه في الوقت المناسب وكذلك التخطيط
المستقبلي لخروج هذه الوحدات بشكل مناسب
بحيث لا يتعارض مع مخططات
في السياق نفسه قابلت الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه السعوديه للكهرباء خالد الجنون
والذي تحدث عن استثمارات للشركه ب 400
مليار ريال في السنوات المقبله
نتكلم عن الاصلاحات سواء الهيكليه او
الاصلاحات الماليه يجب ان نفحص او نتحرى
هل بيئه العمل المناسبه لها الحمد لله
يمكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان لم تكن
همم من افضل الدول في هذا المجال همم
لدينا رؤيه واضحه لدينا منظومه الطاقه
متكامله ومتراف فيما بينها حدود مسؤوليات
واضحه لكل طرف من هذه المنظومه ولدينا
فريق عمل قوي
شباب وشابات يعملون على تنفيذها التوجهات
يعني هنا اصبحت بيئه العمل مناسبه لاي
اصلاحات هيكليه او يصلحات ماليه حبينا
ندخل بالتفاصيل ما هي الاصلاحات الهيكليه
التي عملنا عليها الحمد لله لا بقياده
السمو وزير الطاقه هناك همم صانع قرار او
صانع سياسه اللي هو البوليسي ميكر في
وزاره الطاقه حدود من سوريات واضحه
وتوجهات واضحه هناك منظم واضح
وتوجهات واضحه هناك مقدم خدمه واضحه
واهمها المشترى الرئيس عندما تم خروجه من
الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء بشكل مستقل
واستقلاليه كامله لاداره تجاره طاقه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هل اصلاحات
الهيكليه هي التي سوف تمكنا من تحقيق
الرؤيا وتحقيق مستهدفات منظومه الطاقه
الحمد لله كان في 20 في منى في نهايه 20
20 كان هناك اصلاحات ماليه بدات فيها 20
21 ماكانتنا من معالجه الديون المتراكمه
مثل كانتنا من التمويل الجيد ومكانتنا من
الاستثمار الجيد وبالتالي الحمد لله
القوام الماليه للشركه السعوديه للكهرباء
في العام الماضي وفي هذا العام الى الربع
الثالث متميزه جدا واداءها جيد وبالتالي
سوف تمكننا ان شاء الله من تنفيذ خطتنا
للاستثماريه وتحقيق المستهدفات المطلوبه
على صعيد الخطط الاستثماريه لانه النمو
الهائل في الطاقات المتجدده في المملكه
ونتحدث عن اقله 60 جيجا وات منطقه متجدده
بحلول عام 20 30 طلب استثمارات ضخمه على
طول سلسله القيمه ومن ابرزها قطاع النقل
فبالتالي ما هي وما هو حجم الاستثمارات
همم
المتوقع وما هي نوعيه هذه المشاريع خلينا
نتكلم قبل لا نتكلم عن الطاقه المتجدده
نتكلم عن
حجم الاستثمارات يمكن في الجلسات الحواريه
اللي سمعناها اليوم هناك حوالي 800 مليار
حتكون لمنمومه الطاقه كل بجميع عناصرها
توليد نقل توزيع خدمات منها حوالي 400
مليار للشركه السعوديه للكهرباء هذه سوف
تخصص لي تحقيق ثلاث مساهدفات اللي هو همم
ضمان امدادات الطاقه
ثانيا اللي هي خدمه المشتركين والرضاء
المشتركين والثالثه اللي همم في العمل اذا
اخذنا هذا على مستوى بدايه على مستوى
الطاقه المتجدده زي ما تفضلت هناك اكثر من
60 جيجا تحتاج الى تعزيز شبكات النقل
القائمه وعندنا حوالي من هنا الى 20 30
عندنا حوالي 20 مليار وكذلك انشاء شبكات
جديده لخدمه هذه المواقع والعمل عليها
بحوالي 50 مليار الاجمالي يصل الى 70
مليار تنفذ خلال السنوات القادمه فقط لربط
الطاقه المتجدده وتفعيلها بشكل جيد
هذا مشاهدي ان ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من مستقبل الطاقه شكرا لكرم المتابعه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]